do you guys consider yourselves
traditional women no no no
okay do you guys want traditional
relationships or no no okay so you're
good with the 50. do you want 50 50 the
bills a 100 hundred I don't want 50 50.
I'm saying what do you mean you're both
paying a hundred you want to live in
separate houses
oh yeah
I just want to know how this is gonna
how is this gonna work
well how is this gonna work
I don't fit this I don't know
yeah okay you know what it should be 50
50 right it should be
actually right now for me the comment
for me it should be hundred hundred
because you know they expect the woman
to be at home looking after the kids and
also work also work from my point of
view you have to work as well you know
they put that pressure on you for you to
go to work because they're not the
building's not making sense zombie
Housewives right yeah some be Housewives
but I'm talking like from my point of
view you know I mean like in my
situation I'm working I'm also looking
after the kids I'm doing everything do
you get what I mean but he just goes to
work comes back um so you both work
basically okay but it's like when it
comes to the children so who watches the
kids when you you're at work we have to
go to Nursery oh they go to they go to
daycare now they're grown now but before
that I was doing slowly you're 20 so how
old are your kids
I've got cheer on a six-year-old oh
they're not grown they're not grown
my daughter is 10 so I've got three like
I said my oldest is ten she'll be 11
this year not looking forward to it at
all and then I've got an eight-year-old
and an almost two-year-old yeah crazy
the youngest Rebel it's a Red Bull so I
I have a question for you
um how because I always wonder this like
with like people that send their kids to
Nursery do you worry about them having
more influence on your children than you
will I do yeah but at the same time it's
like if I have to sacrifice something to
gain something you know if if they're at
home with me
I can't put food on the table yeah as
well you know I don't wanna have to deal
with the extra garbage and the stress
and all so however work you know baby go
to Nursery or spend time with you when
you come back home if you're tired it's
okay weekend I'll try and make some time
for you and you guys couldn't survive
off of one income is what you're saying
okay especially you know like the whole
covered and everything is it was just
ridiculous and having to move to
Birmingham
ridiculous so why um I think blessing
joined the show because you said
something about Zim culture you're not a
fan of I'm against him so what what do
you not like about this you're gonna
have them coming from my neck
[Applause]
no I would never date or Mario Zimbabwe
and I've never dated a Zimbabwe man I
never will look at one why
they are just
yeah why I was just leave it there let
me not say anything tomorrow they say if
they have nothing anything nice to say
don't say anything at all right is that
because of an ex or no it's just I don't
really want to put my past too much into
this but it's just the way I was raised
you know my father is obviously
Zimbabwean and the things I want sorry
you're dead to a certain extent
but I love him now
why now
because I feel like he's paying for
everything he's on to me
oh damn
what did he what did he do
well when I was young well not too young
when I was like 17 years old he did
throw me out
and that really hurt
it threw me out because of his wife
that's not my mom
and I was going through so much trauma I
was very suicidal in that time and I
felt like I will shut up
and what what caused you to get thrown
out like was it a fight it was a petty
fight that
paused
that caused me to get for now and you
had no part to play in the fight
I did say something that was wrong okay
now that I look back
because I was trying to find out about
my mom you know I used to ask him about
my mom oh tell me about my mom and he
was just say you know she left you and
that didn't sit right with me because
the fact with my mom's family was
telling me different you know so I just
wanted to know from him like you're my
father tell me about her and
that day even though he was so angry at
me I'm gonna explain everything that
happened in the moment but he was so
angry to the point where I said you're
trying to kick me out just like you did
to my mom and that's what made him
really get extremely angry and I was not
wrong I was right yeah but the way you
tell the story you act like it was all
him and nothing like you didn't do
anything and this prose I feel like I'm
blazing myself like yeah you have a part
to play yeah like everyone does I should
have never said anything to him
but but do you think it was time for me
to say something because that whole you
know mental abuse from
his wife and him it was she wants like
mental abuse I'm not gonna explain
exactly everything because I don't need
to say that you know but there's certain
things that they have put me through
even from when I was younger well it's
just like mentally that's like a pretty
severe accusation you know it was yeah
it was really bad but I don't want to
stay because I know if certain people
see this they don't like that so I'll
just leave it and so because he because
he kicked out he kicked you out at 17 in
a fight that you guys like both had a
part to plan would you admit now she
created it you said you would you
shouldn't have said anything right I
shouldn't have said anything to him
actually just kept it directly to her
because she was the one that had an
issue with me
the whole time but because he acted out
of anger based on whatever he told him
in that moment he was angry at me and I
was also angry I had the right to say
whatever I say you know I'm only human
you think you have the right to say
anything because you're angry I mean I
didn't swear at him
yeah you know that's disrespectful and
my point is yeah but if it was if
someone is shoving you out the house and
throwing your things out the window what
are you gonna do what are you everything
yeah you're not gonna stand you're not
gonna stand there you cannot everything
just kind of came to me like wow
so the way you threw my mom out is
exactly the same way you're doing to me
wait did this happen here or in Zimbabwe
in the UK
but with her yeah with her yeah in the
UK but why is it like a zoom culture's
full if it's just your situation because
all the men in my family are trash
yeah all of them but I think it's as
well that she's been through a lot when
it comes to like the men in her family
so it's just made her
think that way
no I mean I I know um like grape victims
that don't view men a certain way like
you can go through things like that's
like saying if one guy got cheated on by
a woman and saying all women cheat so
it's like you're throwing out an entire
culture what I mean by
certain people have come across as well
as involved one have really tried to
torment my life for me sounds like uh if
you're the common denominator it sounds
like a respect issue because at 17 and
I've got siblings who are Zimbabwean and
I know like a zim household is is built
on respect respecting the elderly
respecting the parents would you say in
that situation where you were respectful
to your parents How can I
not say anything so you wanted me to
keep shutting myself out keep taking
pills to do essay on myself like
literally to commit suicide you wanted
me to carry and do that instead of me
speaking out that was the first time
I've ever spoken out to my dad yeah but
what did she do that was so like
insanely better she was angry she was
going through her own personal issues
obviously she's got whatever she needs
to take for to help her out with her
mental health I understand that now but
then they never told me that they never
told me that she had an issue with her
mental health and that's the reason why
she used to treat me really badly you
know there's been so many things that
happened between me and her to the point
where she even warned me that she wanted
to get rid of me she told me how old did
you like your dad have like a bring it
in
um I think from like 15 was it 15 when I
left slow
no your turn
yeah 15. do you not think it's like um a
teenage kind of like just teenage
emotions because it sounds to me like
you just lashing out like you know my
mom and she was just not having that my
mother was dead from when I was 10 years
old so that's got nothing to do with my
mother
that's a step move on yeah I know it's a
stepmother but when she's coming into a
roof like
literally becoming like a mother in the
house she never treated me like her
daughter she told me I'm not you're not
my daughter I never call me
mom
oh damn and I tried to buy her love
because I never really had love from any
of the women that were in my father's
life
I would do the most I'll buy gifts I'll
I'll cook this I'll clean this do you
know what I mean what was your
relationship with your dad before that
it was amazing so why didn't you find
like like you could communicate with
them why didn't you not do that it's
really because of her um I don't know
but it's like what I hear that because I
had no part to play in it and it's sort
of like a victim mentality it's like
they did everything wrong I did nothing
wrong but they that's the that's the
part though they did do wrong to me they
might have done wrong but I just think
in most situations like you can look
back and say I had a part to play what
did that play when I was younger than
them and they are grown adults I mean I
I can you know I'll use it no I know
what you're gonna do yeah
I'm saying it when I when I was a kid
like I didn't think I absolutely did
things that contributed to say that you
have no accountability just because
you're underage like that's the silliest
thing I've ever heard I I absolutely did
things that contributed to fights with
my parents okay for example let's say
you come back from college right a long
day I'll totally cook this okay fine
I'll cook it I'll clean this I cook it I
clean it I do have a house she's telling
me to do right
just one thing I forgot to do bear in
mind I've got work to do as well I've
got homework to do I've done everything
she said I need to do oh but you forgot
to do this yeah but that's just typical
that's just typical yeah but what she
would do she would not create the issue
from that yeah she goes to my dad like
oh can you imagine she never did this
and she'll purposely mess up the yard
and mess up the house
and make it seem like I didn't do
anything that's that's what I started
thinking like raw that's a bit weird now
that's crazy that is weird and the part
when she thought I was dressing up in a
specific way for my father who said same
to me I was dressing up for my father
that that's why I was like no there's
something wrong with her but then my dad
never told me like oh she's got a mentor
issue but if he did I probably would
have understood like okay you know what
maybe let me be a bit more sensitive let
me not feel some type of way when she
does certain things but because he never
did another time she touched me you know
beating me and all that stuff police
code and everything
that wouldn't have happened if there was
certain things put in place for her not
to even react like that towards me
because I don't understand why the angle
was so much towards me yeah this story
is just this story just seems very crazy
like it's like so she was messing up the
yard and then it was we like it was so
bad to the point where I started feeling
like you know when you get to a point
where you say you know what I'm done and
then you're like taking pills because
you're like I've had enough and the
person is telling you I'm gonna I'm
gonna do something to you like they're
taking certain things I'm not gonna say
what it is but
and then they're standing in the Church
of praising God and the person who's
gonna be giving you like dirty looks I
didn't feel comfortable anywhere I
wouldn't accept College literally at
school literally
so I bro you know you know when your dad
brought it over do you guys have like a
meeting like oh I'm gonna bring this
woman over it's gonna pretty much become
like a mother in the house was I ever
like that discussion yeah he told me
that he's seeing someone and everything
and I was really excited and when she
first came I was so happy I was out my
God I finally have a mom now yeah how
did that first like encounter like how
was that for me I was happy because I
felt like I'm gonna have a mom I'm gonna
have a mom because of it's in my mum's
sister obviously I broke up and my dad
but I was like okay at least now I have
someone that can go to you know because
there's certain things that was
happening to me when I was growing up
you know the feminine stuff I can't talk
to my dad about it so I was happy that
she was coming into the picture you know
I really loved it now when I found out
she had kids and stuff like that I was
like oh my God this is really did you
guys live with the kids as well haircuts
no her kids aren't back home
all right so how how did how was their
reaction like meeting you at first it
was good but I know when it's the the
shift happened when she fell pregnant
do you know things it's just emotions
female emotions when they're pregnant I
was I was too young
oh okay she's acting like this because
she's pregnant and she also got a
certain issue if someone spoke to me and
said okay she's acting like this you
know being blamed for my brother my Step
Brothers do not losing my step brother
is
it's a bit I just think like it's just
hard for me to believe on the outside
looking in that your mom had a problem
with you or yourself sorry sorry sorry
stepmom stepmom had a problem with you
your dad had a problem with you and like
my dad never had an issue to the end
yeah I know but if he's kicking you out
it just seems like you probably had a
part to play like it doesn't seem like
you should demonize all Zimbabwe men
yeah that was kind of a cultural problem
that is a cultural problem because
that's I know I know a little bit like a
little stepmom's a step stepdads
families that get along my my friend is
as a stepmom and they pretty much get
along so I don't know how it's like a
zoom issue because my problem now is
like you going with the narrative like
oh Zim man I like this when we are not
over like this and the couch is not like
this the couch is built on family but
what happens at law is when people go
into like the West coming from Zimbabwe
let's put on Secrets no there's no
family it's all secretive everyone keeps
everything hidden no no you won't try to
pretend children do you think children
are entitled for a parent is able to do
you think a parent should be able to
explain them so stage to a child I think
so yes